بالعوده الى جوله وزير الخارجيه الامريكي
انت بلينكن الى المنطقه والتي بداها الان
من اسطنبول في تركيا تنضم الينا من انقره
مراسله الجزيره فرح الزمان شوقي اهلا بك
معنا كيف يستقبل الاتراك وزير الخارجيه في
زيارته الحاليه وعلى راس الاجنده الحرب
الاسرائيليه على قطاع
غزه يستقبلون هو وهم اتركونا لاهميه هذه
الزياره في هذا التوقيت تحديدا وصل بالفعل
وزير الخارجيه الامريكي لتبدا زيارته
الرسميه ولقاءاته الرسميه يوم غد حيث
سيلتقي بنظيره التركي هكم فيدان الى جانب
احتمال لقاء قد يجمعه بالرئيس التركي رجب
طيب اردوغان وسيكون ذلك في اسطنبول في
الحقيقه الملفات عديده انما بدانا
بالملفات المتعلقه بالشؤون الثنائيه ولا
سيما قضيه مقاتلات اف س ع بين كل من تركيا
والولايات المتحده الامريكيه الى جانب
مساله عضويه السويد في حلف شمال الاطلسي
لكن العنوان العريض في الحقيقه هو مساله
العدوان على غزه سواء من قبل بيان
الخارجيه الامريكيه او حتى من قبل
المسؤولين في الطرف التركي فان هذا
العنوان هو العنوان العريض والعنوان الاهم
لهذه الزياره لكن بطبيعه الحال تركيا التي
كانت قد طرحت في وقت سابق مساله او اقترحت
ان ت تقوم بدور الوساطه فيما يتعلق
بالافراج عن الاسرى قد يبحث هذا الملف من
جديد بحضور وزير الخارجيه الامريكي الى
جانب نقاط ثانيه من قبيل بحث وقف اطلاق
نار وقف اطلاق فوري للنار وقف العدوان على
قطاع غزه لا سما ان تركيا في وقت سابق قد
اكدت على اهميه وضروره تحقيق هذه النقاط
كافه الى جانب المسائل المتعلقه بالنقاط
او بكيفيه لعب انقره ل دور الوصي فيما
يتعلق بمساله الافراج عن المحتجزين في
قطاع غزه لكن ايضا هنالك نقطه هامه تتعلق
بمستقبل ما يجري في غزه ما بعد الحرب
تركيا قد تكون لاعب مهم في هذا السياق لا
سما بوجود اعضاء من حركه حماس على الاراضي
التركيه قد تلعب دورا حاسما في هذا الملف
فيما يتعلق بمساله التواصل الى جانب ذلك
هنالك نقطه قد ذكرت في بيان للخارجيه
الامريكيه تتحدث عن
مساله او ما يوصف امريكيا بالاعتداءات
الحوثيه على السفن التي تمر من البحر
الاحمر قد يبحث هذا الملف ايضا على
الطاوله التركيه الامريكيه اذا هي بدايه
او المحطه الاولى من جوله طويله ستستمر
حتى الحادي من يناير الجاري ستبدا من
تركيا وستشمل دولا ثانيه من قبيل الامارات
المملكه العربيه السعوديه
مصر الاردن الى جانب
اليونان شكرا جزيلا لك على كل هذه
الايضاحات فرح الزمان شوقي مراسله الجزيره
كانت معنا من
انقره